welcome to this video round five of the
candidates tournament this is about the
games Villa against Apollo to quickly
describe the situation of both players
let's start with top all off because
it's easier to describe his played four
drawers and he really didn't get
anywhere near victory in those games he
was more more or less equal all the time
or maybe slightly slightly worse in his
first round game against mama D ro for
instance
yeah and Terrence Midler Hector has
sirillium had a great up in tournament I
mean not great in his view but great to
watch because it was so much so much
action he won a really nice game against
and Draken drew against Kramnik from a
one position Kramnik found large miracle
defense and then he lost against Aronian
after letting after rejecting an early
possibility to basically draw the game
outright and fighting and then going
down so he could have been in a
fantastic situation being on +2 but he's
just on 50% so they both are on 50% and
really would like to win a game I'm sure
about that to get back into the race so
let's see what happened I'm still not
playing in form and the pile of is
playing down the double king 4045 the
Rui
aha so to Paulo is playing um something
that is always difficult to name I think
this is normally called the mother of
variation named after the Danish player
Danish player yeah it's one of those
interesting system where blacks a black
is putting a Bishop on c5 this is very
much related to
in this system which has many names to
catch a variation the shear of variation
of the Neo arc and ghast variation it's
a it's related the thing is with Bishop
c5 black avoids a certain line if you
look at this leg avoids the 9 7 a 4
because after Bishop c5 if white now
place let's say C 3 B 5 Bishop b3 we
come to a position that could have been
reached in the other move Lord as well
but White has four faded this a4 idea
however there is a difference of course
after b5 now white can also put the
bishop on c2 immediately which is what
swindler did and this makes some sense
of course it covers the e4 pawn and
y-term intends a quick deform yet to
pull off now played very actively played
d5
this is the no move very ambitious
ambitious move but it's one of those
moves if white is playing timidly black
will instantly get a good game let's say
I'm the white is not doing something
drastic like d3 black is just a
completely fine here this is in fact
almost almost always the case of black
young gets to play d5 in double King
pawn openings without being punished
with something concrete then d5 is so
normally good let's say let's friends
take the Marshall a gambit there the
punishment is the loss of a pawn but you
see that even there black has got a very
good counter play yeah well something
like these three is just not doing doing
something it's really a played d4 and
this is the most critical move in the
position instantly leading to
complications I don't want to go too
deep into the further opening stage
black took on e4 and white took only
five so interesting early tactics here
black has a choice can also take on f3
this is for instance been played in the
game that Peter Svidler played five
years ago this one like that against
former women world champion at Aneta
stefanova in Gibraltar and he after
those moves he retained a very he got a
very good attack going it seems that to
polyps move is is just just better he
took on d1 rook takes and now captures
the knight yeah white takes on f6 needs
to get the piece back of course and yeah
one thing to quickly show us that in
fact this had been played any game to
Palm off sheer off and sheer off took on
f2
crazy technique the idea is to get this
and and then take the knight I don't
want to describe it in now in detail I
was just trying to show that both
players have some experience with this
position from the white side from the
black side so it's not like they're on
unknown territory and we see that the
moves are here up to now have been
played quite quickly okay now to pawn
off took on f3 and white needs to
capture on f6 and nothing else and now
an interesting move black simply
recaptures so we have a really funny
pawn structure now it's equal material
but black no it's not equatorial black
as a pawn up but he's got this funky
chulaporn especially the pawn f3 is
really remarkable and really sets the
course of the whole game let's see speed
I played Bishop b4 this is certainly the
most logical move putting this Bishop on
the long diagonal and intending to also
just recapture the porn
there should be seven now plate and here
sweeter played a four with what this is
technically a novel team at least
according to my database it's not a
super comprehensive database so there
might be Correspondence games missing or
something like that but it's not likely
this position has been explored in depth
and Grandmaster practice so a forum
what about Bishop f3 we should look at
this this is the most natural looking in
fact this has been played in a game
between a play called feel F against
black flag code Blaschke don't know them
both FM I am strength there black play
turn on castles magical Bishop f4 and 95
in general if you look at this position
you see that white has regained this
pawn so it's equal material the black
has very active pieces got those active
pieces in the center and black is very
nicely developed he's got no development
problems whatsoever and is very active I
think that like does not have any any
sort of problem here in fact it's very
yeah it's more like white is fighting
for equality here I believe simply
because let's say in this position how
do you keep your bishops it's it's
almost impossible to do so if white now
plays a new flag but should be too
looking very passive by the way there's
Bishop g4 for example and the whole
position is somewhat shaky for white
it's simply not very coordinated in the
back rank is very weak something like
that for example now is necessary but
surely this is yeah not much fun so
swindlers a4 is probably better it's
just more more to the point and
aggressive
yeah and blacks reply
is pretty pretty clear he needs to
castlelong he needs to use his
development advantage and took on b5 and
now black can has a choice he played
Knight d5 which I believe is the right
move and if you look at the pile of some
time only nine minutes used he probably
had this at home 8 XP 5 is the
normal-looking move and this is some in
comparison I think it's less aggressive
something like before but should be 692
could be an interesting idea for white
the idea to push c4 is probably quite
interesting if black takes c4 this can
get tricky note that black can never
take there is this checkmate direct
punishment awaiting him so something
like that in fact looks quite good for
what I mean black has made to wanna do
not so precise moves and in this
sequence but you get the idea
black is not caring about that he plays
95 just banking on his superior
development and the fact is that white
now cannot take on a6 this is not
playable look at this the back rank is
simply the issue white has all those
pieces on the back ring and the back
rank is terribly weak here white can
easily lose quickly something like that
for example no he had the chain first
and here black has something like that
and why does not going to survive the
next couple of moves this is just too
much pressure you cannot take because of
rooty one mate and all black's pieces
are fantastically placed so even if
Shore notice white will lose material
here you cannot take on a six rook a six
is slightly better but also after Bishop
c6 very risky business it's always this
very weak back rank
Swilly replayed the Benham who played
Bishop f4 and this is just much more
sensible get your pieces developed and
also prepare a knight move so that
finally the rooks are connected and the
bank rank is not so weak
yeah Bishop f4 and now the problem took
on b5 with the bishop
this was the ideals of 95 this maneuver
to get the bishop into play and there's
even this possibility where blacks
Bishop is yeah entering White's position
with very active plane yeah and this is
not much fun to play for white I mean
Svidler was spending lots of time and
blacks activity is really getting
getting enormous layer enormous ly
annoying and he has a pawn extra like I
mean it's it's a trip triple porn and
black's pawn structure is looking like
Swiss cheese but it's still upon so not
great result for swedeland very good for
the power off yeah it played night a3
here they're our only alternative which
makes some sense in my book is 92 but he
probably didn't like that because of
various things one thing being this
should be to look at this Knight come on
this should be too
yeah me too oh yeah
rookie one probably not very active and
then probably just drop g8 and after
something like you can say this and this
g3 wide it's just somewhat its passive I
mean the knight is not doing much on d2
and especially the rook is not doing
much yeah black has various ways to try
to improve we can use the H born if he
wants just one way to go about it and
yeah it's it's not great I mean like
Knight e3 I think it's fine it's maybe
not better than 92 but I understand the
idea behind it 92 seems very passive
yeah and now to Paula first took on d1
this is based on a concrete idea it it
does not look too logical to be honest
to capture but he had the concrete
calculation to to back it up
in fact I think it's probably better in
this position to play Bishop b2 just
like in the line before when the night
was on d2 I mean I think in those lines
it's it's black who is calling the shots
white he is also in trouble he needs to
take really check something like that is
immediately leading to big problems just
before for example 93 is good but
there's also another funny line if blank
I was here and you try to defend with
this black can even catch a here check
check yeah and this is just whoops not
like that it can take here that's better
and you can even promote with the night
of year to a night if you want it's just
one line to show that white is in real
big danger so on we should look mostly
at that too to capture and yeah well
this position here is not much fun to
play like is just better here it's
tricky though to to find out what's
what's the best possible continuation
and therefore I understand that to pile
of went for form for his move it also
looks attractive what he is playing with
maybe this is even better it's it's not
too hard to tell what you can get the
problem back if he wants but this is
just a case where this is not it is
terribly dominated by black sir
like the bishops it's just a very good
position for black 92 was a very decent
Bishop e2 was a very decent yeah well he
took and played Bishop b2 here this is
of course looking quite similar
the difference is of course white can
now go to d5 and this is certainly what
the power of had calculated but it seems
that he has missed something along the
way here up to now he had played rather
quickly no he took a ball and then
played rook g8 and I believe that this
is actually a really big mistake if he
is not doing that playing a move like
let's say Bishop to d6 for example then
this position is probably around equal I
believe that roopd one sports some of
its his advantage but this is this is
probably about equal black still has the
pawn but white now has active pieces I
mean the rook it's on d5 now it's just
not too bad
the problem with his mudras he played
rook g8 and why is this a problem yeah
it's it's a tricky move of course
because yeah wow this is fun we can look
at this white can take the piece but
here he's actually forced to accept the
draw like a threatening look f1 mate and
after h3 we had to draw yeah white
cannot try to win by escaping Jack check
yeah funny line the end black is winning
with g5 coming yeah - Parris move
through created it it looks good it
looks aggressive but and it introduces
this piece sacrifice but yes Victor does
not need to take it I mean he certainly
calculated this but not by now he can
just play g3 simple moves and what
exactly as is black doing now the
problem is h7 is - saying you just have
played rook g8 and this means that now
the H pawn is saying what should black
do yeah it seems to me that the best
when you need to do something about your
hanging bishop now is to go Bishop to b6
after which the capture not quite sure
where the Ruka should go now let's say
here - of - here Kings yeah and then we
continue from here probably something
like age four now wanna capture first
age four yeah this ninety six this might
be a bit a bit annoying maybe even
taking and then a strong yeah this
position is still very much playable for
black cami the computer likes white here
but like has some play I mean he's got
the the bishops you know and what's King
is not 100% safe I mean this is what he
should have done I believe but to paula
played very hard to understand why I
really don't know what the calculation
error lost when he played it because
strategically speaking it looks terrible
he took on a three giving up this this
good Bishop against the the knight on
the rim and the strange thing is that
after Bishop a three
here's Villa he thought for a moment he
didn't recapture mmediately look at this
about three minutes and he has really
like simply could have taken age seven
and for some reason he must have
discarded this idea but it's it's simply
winning the game I believe we can just
take the speed of this pawn and I really
don't see what what black is doing
against it and the problem is you always
have Bishop f5 check if black plays this
to attack the bishop you can just give
the check check and then capture so it's
just the position of the game with the
h-bomb gone and I mean the two bishops
and the H pawn
very simple plan like it's just
completely Nastya
I really don't know it would be
interesting as I didn't have the chance
to to to watch the press conference
after the game would be very interesting
to learn what Sweden had calculated or
what both players had calculated Bishop
h7 just seems like a flat-out win to me
it just nets the pawn for no particular
compensation and with the bishop pam
it's too much yeah well Sweden
recaptured I don't I don't know why I
don't know why really it's not like he
automatically recaptured sometimes it
happens your opponent just takes a piece
and for some reason you don't consider
intermediate moves and just recapture
but he spent three minutes and he was at
the board I saw that on video he was
really thinking so he had some idea why
it didn't take but I don't know what it
was okay here black managed to play
Knight g6 and save the pawn for the
moment however the position is already
more comfortable for white this Bishop
e3 was simply assembly abandon there's
no other way to to describe it yeah it's
a position where black enjoys an extra
pawn but look at the ports isolated
isolated isolated triple pawn and an
isolated pawn so this means was Jesus is
is more structured than than blacks
blacks pawns it's um it's really
difficult now in the long run to to keep
all your pawns and and protect them or
it's very very difficult against this
active rook and the bishops we see that
in the next couple of move through p8
check check do I just trying to improve
of course the issue is the King he wants
to move the H pawn and then get the King
involved the king is not playing which
is black so only real asset iam okay g4
a5
Adri as mentioned with the idea to
activate the king black plate age five
he wants to exchange pawns this is very
understandable Bishop a4 check and here
I think is the yeah the decisive mistake
really king CA it is still very much
very much defensible I mean why it is
more comfortable and easier to play but
the game continues after King a6 the
problem is after the capture and rook a
d8 that the king is in some trouble now
this is almost a checkmate you only need
to control b5 and it will be a maid and
the mating threats at the side of the
board really get ya get two too much to
handle
now it's a real threat look a a
checkmate
so c6 was played and I look b8 yeah this
King is just just a big liability night
c4 to cover b6 and I'll Bishop to d4 and
one by one the pawns get targeted target
target target they can all easily be
attacked and the same time Lex King is
in trouble
yeah c5 was played and here the first
one is going check it here's the second
one they fall for piece by piece
it's um now we come to the point where
white actually has an extra pawn the
only drawing hope is of course yeah
opposite colored bishops but there are
still rooks on the board which already
is the difference and white is two
passes so it's not like just one pawn
it's more like two pawns as the double
porn is not so relevant here still it's
not completely trivial from
pick up one of you and we see that there
are so things to to solve problems to
solve Bishop g5 oopsie form yeah in fact
here I believe that we'll have made
nineteen Eckerd news he probably should
play king h2 and give up this point to
get the h-bomb rolling this is very
important the age upon the age pawns
promotion Square is a dark square so
this gives quite excellent winning
chances I think probably what will win
he played instead he played Bishop d2
and it seems that here black can retain
some chances to fight but somehow he
didn't play it I mean he had six minutes
on the clock but the part of didn't play
rook age for which I think story sir is
offering some chances to fight he played
Roxy 7lu cage for it's a quite
interesting if you look at this it takes
the pawn what really needs the edge pawn
that's the winner pawn here and now
Bishop everyone yep attacking on h3 so
rook takes f3 is the the only move and
after this like just a place like this
and continues with two points down and
this is actually taught it or easy to
win I believe if you look at this what
should why do can try to yeah to use the
C pawn the problem is look at the King
it can never go anywhere this is just
Jack giving it the way go here so you
lose the pawn it said it's Ricky I mean
the C pawn alone will probably not win
so why it so needs to solve some some
problems in the game he played rook c7
and well after that it's it
now the age porn is running yeah
the h-bond will decide the game so just
a matter of simple technical play yeah
kuku tries to go back but even this
wouldn't have helped
it's always nice is she with checkmate
this mate you know the the bishop is
simply the right one for the h-bomb rook
c8 was played age 7 yeah yeah the part
of resigned to the only move to stop the
porn for now is shelf is this end all
we've got
checkmate this acute mate again so a
very important very important game for
the further course of the tournament a
good winning bias Villa who is back in
contention being on on +1 again really
an up and down tournament she certainly
Binda the most exciting player to watch
endure the tournament yeah the very
disappointing result for what Apollo who
really displayed the great preparation
in this in this game I mean this look at
this here round ta so what's in his
preparation it had a really great active
position but then with some leaves like
the the capture this sequence of moves
really turned the good position into a
difficult one and Bishop III after that
he really had had big trouble to to play
this position in fact Bishop h7 here
would have would have won the game I
guess pretty convincingly for for what
I'm not really sure why he didn't play
it it's always so easy after the game
you can yeah you can sit there in your
office so have your coffee switch on the
engine and the tilts your Bishop h7
White's wins it's not comparable to a
situation in a in a real game where you
only need to calculate but I really
don't this is one of the cases where I
have a hard time
understand because it's not much nothing
much complicated to calculate really
yeah so what does this mean for the rest
of the tournament sweet alarm plus one
he's back in the race to PI love with
this losses on minus one after five
rounds and considering that you probably
need plus 3 or plus 4 I don't really see
him winning four or five games he's the
kind of player who was always able to
win win a game because of his
enterprising style but this game it
didn't I don't know it does not look
like he's in terribly terribly great
shape but it seems so on yeah tough one
for to part of but an interesting game
to watch obviously yeah I hope you liked
the coverage for this game thanks for
watching
I'll be back tomorrow with round six